[Music]
you're trying to hypnotize my Americans
I'm trying to hypnotize you Alfred
Hitchcock said you could never put a
hypnotism in a movie because it doesn't
work with Jordan Peele proved him wrong
there are a lot of people that pointed
out the different things to pay the
hidden messages that they saw after
watching it so I kind of want to see it
you can answer a few Oh God
here we go they were pointing out how
you were separating your Froot Loops and
your milk
I mean mothers and the way yeah so they
said that the the theory is that that
was segregation I think that's true
whose idea was it to have that scene I'm
not sure if it was Allison or Jordans
idea with the milk and the Froot Loops
and but it was definitely their
collaboration about how creepy and eerie
it is for an adult to be drinking milk
out of a straw and eating Froot Loops
one by one in a very kind of creepy
sadistic way you don't have to give him
your ID because you haven't done
anything wrong
maybe be nice in peak when Rose is
sticking up for Chris when the police
pulled him over is that her avoiding a
paper trail I that's a good theory and
there's a lot of truth to that the
backstory is to you know shine a light
on something that's all too obvious
going on with the police and law
enforcement and treatment of different
individuals another one so the tea cup
that the mom was using was that symbolic
of how slave masters used to summons
their house slaves that's a theory again
you'd have to ask Jordan not to my
knowledge
cellphones were the thing that we're
breaking the hypnosis for a lot of the
people that had been hypnotized and
taken where the phones used as a nod to
how police brutality has affected our
country and it's been documented through
bones not to my knowledge
okay so that one's false I think that
one would be a stretch the the phones
were a device for the the flash to you
know cause the quote-unquote seizure
okay so the seizure is the reason that
they were broken out of hypnosis correct
you know sorry man get out
[Music]
you